[Music]
eldon ring
is an action rpg
set in a dark fantasy world
enter the lands between a place of
boundless scale an untold mystery
where your journey to reveal the fabled
elden ring
unfolds
thou should take the crap
the lands between is ruled by great
heroes
those who have inherited the blood of
queen america
someone must extinguish
thy flame
[Music]
you play as a descendant of the
tarnished
a group of heroes once banished from the
lands between
[Music]
when the elden ring was shattered
the very source of the erd tree's
blessing was disrupted and eventually
the exile tarnished found themselves
being led once more by long lost grace
i
offer you an accord
as a tarnished you'll set off on a
journey to the lands between
rich with mystery
and fraught with danger
to face the former heroes of this world
[Music]
the lands between
comprises massive dense play spaces
teeming with threats and brimming with
the unknown
you'll face many fearsome enemies
meet a wide variety of characters
and discover hidden dungeons
those who brave these catacombs
mines and caves
will find themselves adequately rewarded
[Music]
travel far enough
and you'll eventually reach a legacy
dungeon
a complex and intricately built dungeon
map
that connects seamlessly with
surrounding landscape
these sprawling environments
offer their own style of tension and
exploration creating a different feel
from that of your journey through the
overworld
[Music]
the lands between are vast and offer a
high level of freedom for explorers
use the map to assist with navigation
place beacons and markers
for places that catch your eye
or fast travel to previously discovered
checkpoints
for faster traversal summon torrent your
trusty spectral steep at any time
anywhere outside of dungeon areas
torrent offers excellent mobility
making it possible to venture further
and higher into the lands between
throughout your journey you'll meet with
many characters
each with their own motives and goals
help them pursue these goals
to reveal their backstories and learn of
your shared place in this world
[Music]
player freedom extends far beyond
exploring the lands between
your character can be fully customized
from appearance to armor and ability
become a warrior
specializing in close quarters combat
a caster
that excels at sorcery or incantations
or of course you could attempt to master
a little of everything
an extensive lineup of equipment weapons
magic and skills are waiting to be
discovered
allowing you to develop your character
in whatever way you wish
a keen adventurer may find item crafting
useful
using materials picked up along the way
many different items can be crafted on
the fly
from arrows and firebombs to cured meats
and other consumables that offer a range
of benefits
[Music]
the player may call upon spirits to
fight alongside them
spirits vary in type and behavior
so summoning them according to the
situation is key
in particularly dangerous situations
you may choose not to engage the enemy
using stealth to outflank or escape
you can also join with players from
other worlds
to journey explore and challenge
tenacious foes together
the expansive world of the lands between
is abound with danger
interest the mythological drama
begin your adventure and reveal its
secrets for yourself
your eyes tarnished
rise and become the elden law
[Music]